quatre des chaudières ne sont toujours
pas à lui mais non je n'en vois pas le
besoin
nous faisons une moyenne très jeunes
rats le vrai que j'inaugure du titanic
toi faire les gros titres au vent vous
permet apparemment suisse mais je
préférerais ne pas pousser le moteur
tant qu'ils ne sont pas rôdés ouais
voilà ce qui en plus moi j'ai payé point
de semaine donc j'aime autant que ça
dure une semaine pour la bouffe mais
quelques lots rieuse fin de carrière
pour vous que ce voyage si nous
arrivions à new york mardi soir à la
surprise générale on ferait la une des
journaux du matin mais c'est bien il a
dit c'est bien comme ça parce que après
ses impressions j'ai un iceberg est tout
le temps que non mais ce serait chiant
quand même finir sur un exploit ou cher
edouard bravo
forme
content que ça risque que ces tarifs là
pas à t'inquiéter pour ça la première
chose que je ferai quand je suis rentré
chez moi
mais sinon vous voulez pas quoi mettre
en quarantaine
juste pour être sûr je propose avaler
qu'est ce qui se passait c'est
dégueulasse mais ou alors un rapport
avec l'extra justement la dernière fois
c'est pas sérieux
là on entend clairement nouveau décret
ok on ne touche pas mais si s'ils
touchent le même tu le même parce que là
il va me paraît hélas on fait le bon et
ben moi si vous me cherchez je suis dans
ma chambre enfermé jusqu'à la fin des
temps bonne chance
tout le temps
apprêtez-vous souffle
pour rien appris et abris
quand il va chercher non non
emmène sa mère à l'abri
non pas tout c'est superman en fait donc
du coulis peut voler peut soulever les
maisons et tout ce que ça lui il ya les
plus en forme que je
même pour tous
c'est le chien en plus t'es même pas du
bon ben on s'en fout en fait on perd lé
brésil invasive même sans cette superbe
anja temps-là bon et échanger
bon moi j'ai plus le temps d'y aller par
contre toi luke tait superman qui va
hyper vite tu reviens personne ne voit
rien dalton le sommaire
là tu as le temps
la tête
là dans le temps
là c'est compliqué là c'est très chaud
et là c'est mort elle est mort et aurait
pris dans une tornade comme ça c'est les
stats sont nuls qui valent éléments
monsieur
bienvenue au fight club la première
règle du fight club et il est interdit
de parler du fight club
la seconde règle de fight club et il est
interdit de parler du fight club
je suis chez moi vous avez dit deux fois
la même chose non troisième règle du
fight club
quelqu'un crie stop quelqu'un s'écroule
on n'en peut plus de combats il ya deux
voies
aha
oui
regarde ça
i tu vois ce que je vois
plus
hé les gars y'a un truc là
avoir pu choquer j'en à isbergues
si c'est ce qu'il faut faire pour avoir
plus chaude qu'on pas sur moi pour le
faire avec toi
royal c'est parti voilà
un iceberg droit devant c'est ce que
j'aime bien en fait
la race est rasé ah oui ben non on l'a
pas rasé on l'a carrément percuté la le
bruit le bruit tap a entendu un énorme
bruit
personne n'a cru dans un film